purse Wayne meets Clark Kent I love it I
love bringing people together Lex it is
a pledge out wow it is a good grip you
should not pick a fight with this person
hello I'm Lucy from gamespot joined here
by luke westaway from cnet we've both
seen Batman vs Superman and we're kind
of desperate to talk about it and so
we're gonna do a spoiler field chat
we're going to touch upon like the five
biggest plot points from the movie
admittedly all of them have been spoiled
by the trailer in some regard that's
true but nevertheless this is your
official spoiler warning so if you
haven't seen the movie turn back now be
warned and don't watch any trailers as
our first point we would talk about is
the fact that Batman either just
outright breaks or really strongly bends
here's no kill rule yeah bama noni
really has one rule but you can mess
around with the outfit and the car and
everything but sort of the one thing
that makes batman batman is that he's a
vigilante Hugh doesn't kill people
released tries very hard not to and I
get that it's very dark vision that you
know of the film like the DC Universe I
Zack Snyder imagines it is quite is it
like unremittingly bleak yeah really
depressing but that said especially
seeing as this the first time you're
meeting this Batman and it's his first
sort of on screen outing yeah it kind of
it's a bit getting off on the wrong foot
to have his bat wing like Tokyo drifting
around the corner and a bunch of machine
guns coming out and like blowing up some
cars at a full of people yeah I do you
think I agree no I mean cuz I that's got
the point I'm trying to make is like
Batman is really he's had 20 years of
fighting crime in Gotham he's fed up he
is fed up he's a holiday Alfred's on his
back Oh giving him all this and so
Batman it's just sort of he's at the end
of his tether and what he started to do
is to brand this is a plot way I did not
understand yeah he started to brand
enemies like what he's taken a bat
around yeah heated it up somehow and
brands Daenerys and that for some reason
as a death wish if when they're in
prison but if you think about it
Blackgate prison in Gotham City at least
seventy percent of the criminal
we'll be there because of Batman so I
don't understand how this is a death
wish because then everyone would be dead
yeah you'd think if if you were in
prison and someone came up and they had
like a Batman brand you just be like oh
cool you had a fight with Batman what
was it like let's trade stories let's
try and figure out the weaknesses in his
in his armor in his fighting style it
but like again like when I was actually
watching the movie that didn't it didn't
occur to me as being especially stupid
it was just afterwards after the movie
finished like it don't just sort of
holds together while you're watching it
I think I didn't hate film but
afterwards I was a bit there's some tour
that's really really terrific scenes
that's really really terrific moments
but confused confused all right next up
uh Lois Lane wish there's there's no
reason why Superman's love interest Lois
Lane has to be just Superman's love
interest and exist solely to be rescued
but it does feel a little bit in this
film like that is her name I mean how
many times I should get rescued in this
film as far as I can remember three
times and you know she's she's got other
stuff to do apart from that but not a
whole lot and and she's a little bit
frustratingly sort of slow off the mark
and and she's not like I think we've
become used to superhero movies where
they have sort of mortal human ordinary
sidekicks but who turn out to be sort of
more helpful than you think kind of
foggy Nelson a daredevil or don't bring
fog in I know you don't like foggy but
it's great go foggy but we've got used
to that and so when for example Lex
Luthor pushes Louis of a skyscraper in
an effort to attract and lure a Superman
it's a Superman trap the lowest knows
about and then Superman catches her and
lowers her gently to the ground and then
they sort of stand there for out five
seconds looking at each other and Louis
doesn't feel the need to voice like
don't go back up there is trap yeah I
don't want to nitpick over the script
but i think that's that's emblematic of
a problem with her character that i hope
they fix going forward because she can
be cool i was thing like in Man of Steel
she figured out she figured out that
Clark kent/superman like before anyone
else I think even before he figured it
out Lois is also everyone to offer like
the dumbest moment of this movie and
that is saying a lot uh this is
near the end yeah so Lex Luthor's found
a big bunch of kryptonite Bruce Wayne
has stolen it killing a bunch of dudes
in the process and is fashioned it into
a spear that can kill Kryptonians if you
know the piers are skinning again is dad
like a regular spear those are the rules
so Clark and Bruce Kison stop there
fighting Batman doesn't get a chance to
use the spear on Superman and it's just
sort of lying on the floor so Lois takes
it I guess in an attempt to get it away
from clog but she dumps it in a pool of
water I think she thinks she's trying to
be helpful but like there's just a pool
of water like it's not it's not like her
it's not safe there right yeah it's not
like reach she dives in to try and get
it when she needs turns out they need
the spear to feel the big boracay
monster thing that sort of pops up at
the end doomsday right Davis but then
like she can't get out and she's trapped
at super nice to rescue her and it's
she's just sent up being unhelpful again
just comply mean just born her income
into complete uselessness
all right next up we're going to talk
about the confusing motivations of Lex
Luthor and his ultimate creation doom
say mmm Lex Luthor has given a lot of
free rein in this movie to sort of be
part of whatever government think tank
or research team he wants and again
because you sort of haven't met him
before you're a bit like who is this guy
he looks about 18 in the knees in charge
of a company and I guess he's a genius
oh wait well he you can tell he's a
genius billionaire playboy because he
wears trainers to work and he plays
basketball and he doesn't have an office
so when the government officials come he
meets them in like a food court yeah in
his office he's got this like Mark
Zuckerberg vibe going on which I guess
in surprising considering his Jesse
Eisenberg like much like Berg in the
social network I thought jesse eisenberg
was trying we may get a really good go
of it but like he's easy the lex luthor
dialogue is weird he sort of talks in
these slightly tortured metaphors a lot
about demons and philosophy in humans
and that kind of seems to be his whole
motivation right he just wanted to see
talk about God's I thought his whole
motivation was that his dad hit him as a
child because that seems to be the only
real motivation that he has that's
definitely the only revelation that we
get about next near the ends is were in
a throwaway line mentions that you know
his dad hit him which is horrible
possibly not dealt with in a
particularly sensitive way in the film
and then quickly sort of glossed over he
has a kind of idiosyncratic dialogue
which I can imagine on the script look
sort of great but when you actually sort
of see it he's kind of like going the
color the bell has been wrong ding ding
ding ding oh and the big way the bit
where he genuinely says ahoy hoy hoy hoy
no no so he finds the Kryptonite he it
ends up getting stolen and he doesn't
seem to care about that at all which is
quite bizarre but then what he does is
he finds the downed Krypton ship from
man of steel I don't he doesn't find it
he gets given it by the US government
yeah thanks for that government if this
is what he's doing I dread to think what
sucker bugs up to
there's this weird slightly tortured
plot points about like they'll let him
they'll they'll give him like the alien
ship and zod's courts but they won't let
him import some kryptonite and it's just
like an import tax thing which is an
almost Phantom Menace grade boring level
of plot point so I guess Lex Luthor
surely he can move a rock from like one
continent to another it's just you know
finds the ship he has general Zod's
corpse so if you were if you were
annoyed that Zod got killed by a neck
snap you're gonna be even more annoyed
about what happens to him because Lex
cuts his hand and mixes the DNA and that
somehow makes doomsday yep so he's a big
DC villain who is he's basically one of
the Superman's like big bad guys if you
come at him with any kind of force he
absorbs it and can use that energy
himself also his bone because he's
always cut he's like constantly evolving
as well and the bone shards sticking out
of his arms can like pierce the
Kryptonian skin and was just very
bizarre and it looked a lot like the
cave troll from other rings oh my god
like the cave troll from long ago also
he had though genitals and you know like
his only purpose was there to to like
unite everyone they pulled all these
strings together to fashion a bad guy
that we would care about no one cares
about no it's a place it's a plot point
I guess directly lifted from the first
Avengers movie right you kind of have
like an alien force that no one's
particularly interested in but what
you're interested in is seeing all of
these heroes who've been fighting all
along to sort of and finally make
friends and sort of work together I
would say that the superhero team work
in batman vs. superman is not as well
choreographed like Batman doesn't have a
lot to do for the sort of final conflict
just sort of stands out Wonder Woman is
the morning get stuff done you get stuck
in we like Wonder Woman right she was
cool she was cool
okay the seeds for the justice league
movie have really awkwardly in the
middle of the movie been sown hmm so
there's no post credits tease know so
you know you can feel free to feel free
to leave run to the bathroom probably
cuz it's a long movie and instead Bruce
Wayne managed to hack lexcorp's network
his Dropbox yeah essentially he's all up
in his twisted dm's amazingly like to
lisa has created really well labeled
folders on the eventual members of the
Justice League so we get our first look
for some reason there's no green arrow
maybe he was busy filming his TV show we
do get see new flash you get to see Ezra
Miller as the flash which is odd because
there's so much world-building going on
in batman vs. superman and if there's so
much sort of being crammed in that you'd
think that the little bit of worlds that
DC is already built like the flash TV
show you think they would keep that
little bit of world for the big world
film now you know i mean a new actor you
flash and then finally get see jason
momoa as Aquaman this is the bit that
kind of made me laugh because for a
metahuman who spends his life underwater
I've never seen a more uncomfortable
looking a Aquarian aquarium under Merman
it just sort of he's there and he's less
it isn't a sunken ship and he's got a
kind of tried and he's going look down
and get off my lord what is this camera
I liked him I have to say I liked I
liked how Aquaman looked I like how he
saw there's a bit where he kind of goes
who shot through the scene you know he's
like Superman but underwater so like a
much worse Superman and we also get to
see cyborg yes yeah that famous so I
warned you been waiting for kids so just
League I mean it hasn't really got me
excited about it there was a really
strained conversation between Batman and
Wonder Woman at the end where they
basically said Justice League good idea
great yes we're in um that was easy
Justice League formed and
sort of hinted at the bad guy yeah
Darkseid's yes that's right so in
weirdly and again you mentioned this how
odd it is how weirdly these teasers are
positioned in film but the kind of tease
for darksiders like writing them right
in the middle right where Batman has
extended vision or is it a dream or a
premonition in the desert which
incidentally it contains all of the bits
that you thought were cool this through
the trailer so so you know don't expect
those to be actual plot points in the
movie yeah weird very crazy dream
and finally probably the big twist
superman is dead no nor is he it'll be
such a shame if he died cuz he's so
great he's such a great card so doomsday
with his bone shards stabs him right
through the heart blammo ah and Superman
dies dies and is buried and he next to
his gone dad and there's a parade and
this under the world weeps as one for
the loss it's funny how they've turned
them into a martyr again you know like
him now yeah the thing that it was quite
frustrating i found watching the film
because there's quite an ending it takes
quite a long time to end it return of
the kings it's Nate's got a return of
the king sort of vibe to it the ending
and it feels like the film all this time
is asking you to believe that Superman's
dead and it's like come on like that you
know these films exist in context will
we know that the whole point of this
film is to select make more Superman
movies we know is not dead so it really
lacks that dramatic but there's just no
way you believe he's dead so having to
watch like his funeral is a bit like but
it better leave now the traffic will be
bad yeah and also that like tehama the
point home that he's definitely not dead
is the final shot of the movie is a
close up on his casket and Lois is just
thrown soil down you know they're just
one handful and then she's off yeah I
mean no time for grieving and the soil
begins to rise so you know that he's
clearly using some kind of Krypton
powers to heal himself to freak everyone
out I would like Superman to come back
as a ghost that's probably a comic arc
as well and have to be a super ghost so
I think I think the most annoying bit
about the whole Superman death is that
everyone knew he wasn't dead and yet
that sequence still went on for about 20
minutes I feel like we've been quite
negative about I mean I know we're
talking about like the biggest questions
we had I've seen a movie yeah did you
hate it you hang out I didn't hate it I
didn't hate it I actually like there was
some isolated moment I did really really
love i love the way look
special the visual effects I loved a lot
about the movie but that doesn't mean
that I can't question a lot of it that's
right and a lot of it didn't make sense
so if you've got any questions comments
concerns about Batman vs Superman chuck
them in the comments below come find us
on Twitter Luke at luke westaway I'm at
least James games and for more on Batman
vs Superman make sure you keep your eyes
peeled to gamespot com and also see